la reapertura de los clubes nocturnos el
fin del mandato de trabajar desde casa y
la eliminación de las mascarillas al
aire libre francia se prepara a levantar
las restricciones por coronavirus a
partir del 2 de febrero pero mientras el
país sigue viendo un aumento de las
infecciones por un micrón es este un
calendario adecuado algunos expertos
creen que si las mascarillas al aire
libre son por el momento algo que se
basa en muy poca evidencia científica
como para mantenerlas los límites de
aforo en los estadios si pasamos de
5.000 a 10.000 a 20.000 personas siempre
y cuando a partir del lunes estos
establecimientos exijan el pase de
vacunación
pero mientras front se registraba el
jueves más de 400.000 contagios
por tercer día consecutivo
otros científicos dicen que es mejor
mantener la precaución
en este momento el verdadero mensaje que
hay que enviar es tengan cuidado todavía
estamos en medio de la ola de omikron
mientras tanto el pase de vacunación
entrará en vigor a partir del lunes lo
que significa que un test negativo ya no
será suficiente para acceder a muchos
lugares públicos pero convencer a esta
medida a los que aún no se han vacunado
yo sí para ser
no estoy seguro de que para las personas
decididamente contrarias a la vacunación
vayan a cambiar su posición pero en
términos de política sanitaria a mí no
me parece que tengan un beneficio
importante además del pase sanitario más
de 5 millones de franceses con
posibilidad de vacunarse siguen sin
hacerlo